let's hear from people in the audience
on the Friday show we go to the phones
except we really don't we actually use
Discord you can join the David Pacman
show Discord absolutely free at
davidpackman.com
Discord and uh it's really an
extraordinary thing as a reminder to
everybody who's waiting the format for
your nickname if you want to talk to me
is name and location or location and
name those are the rules so for example
we're going to go to Juni from Florida
Junie from Florida is our first caller
today Juni what's going on
uh hello David do you hear me yes I do
great great uh my question for you is um
what everything you know going on with
the uh current Republican party with uh
you know uh Banning books trying to
restrict voting
um what do you think uh is the future of
uh the Republican party in your opinion
well I don't think it's determined at
this point in time I I as I've said for
a while now
um it looked like the 2022 Maga Red Wave
wasn't going to materialize and it
didn't and the question now is what
happens in 2024
there really doesn't seem to be anything
that will stop Trump from being the
Republican nominee short of trump
himself and what I mean by that is one
arrest so far five million dollar sexual
assault and defamation a verdict against
him on Tuesday potentially another
arrest coming out of Georgia in uh
between July and September is roughly
what's estimated
could all of that take him off the
campaign Trail in such a way that he's
just not viable but the Republican party
for now does seem to still hold Trump as
its leader and I don't know what's going
to prevent him from being the nominee so
then the question comes
uh becomes the 2024 general election
obviously if Trump is re-elected
president in 2024 which I don't think is
as far-fetched as some do Trump's
actually ahead of Biden in some polling
already if that happens then I will be
ready to say the Republican party in a
more permanent way has jumped the shark
for lack of a better term however if
trumpism is again defeated in 2024
assuming Trump's the nominee but loses
I believe at that point particularly
with Trump being an even older guy at
that point in time it will be
essentially open season on abandoning
Maga fully by the Republican party which
may be what saves them at the end of the
day
okay yeah that sounds uh I you know I I
agree with that and uh can you do you
mind if I just ask you uh one more quick
uh question sure
I agree uh do you think with the
Republican party going against you know
the lgbtq community uh stigmatizing them
and uh very very negative ways uh do you
think it's fair to maybe call the modern
day Republican party fascistic or
proto-fascist in a way yeah I think you
know with a lot of this stuff these are
mostly
linguistic conversations then then
operational or or policy but I think
there's no question that what you're
seeing among the Maga movement is a a
sort of neo-fascist light
authoritarianism of sorts which would
like to be much more hardcore if we
didn't have some of the checks and
balances we have in the United States
they'd likely succeed in becoming much
more of that but um I I do think that uh
wannabe fascists
is probably as good a term as any
yeah I agree with that
um well okay David that's really all the
questions I've had and I don't want to
hold up so you know I'll just let you
get to uh more callers well one question
for you is Juni short for something it's
not a name I'm super familiar with
oh no that's okay it's uh it's a
nickname I go by because my full name is
Leroy McGraw Jr and so uh Juni just
comes from Junior got it okay very good
that makes that actually makes a lot of
sense all right Judy thank you for the
call I appreciate it no problem David
enjoy the rest of your weekend sir you
too there goes Juni from Florida if
you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below